the latest recruits to the vaccination
army
community pharmacists bringing the
life-changing jab to street corners like
this one in macclesfield
we've been here for 30 years i know
four generations of some families
so we're hardwired into this community
so i feel very close to the people that
i'm vaccinating
and it's a very personal experience for
them pharmacists are seen as a vital way
of helping the vaccine program close the
gap
on the virus this last week or two has
been really really scary from the
from the death rate point of view i mean
it's i'm
healthy you know i don't go to the
doctors but even so
you know you're in that age range and
therefore you know
you you're very vulnerable it'll be a
while though before we can all get the
dose when we're shopping for shampoo
right so it's going in this side there
are just six chemists offering
vaccinations across england
compared to more than a thousand gps and
hospitals
for some corners of the uk more centers
and more doses
can't come soon enough the midlands the
north
eastern yorkshire and the south east
have all received more than 340
000 doses but they've been fewer than
200 000
in london and the east of england that
means just
2.9 of adults in london have had a dose
and 3.7 percent in the east of england
compared to 5.5 in the best performing
region
of the northeastern yorkshire it's a
similar picture for the over 80s
with around 30 vaccinated in the east of
england and london
compared to almost 50 percent in the
northeastern yorkshire
the vaccines minister said government
was working to end the regional
disparities
there is a variation clearly as you can
see in the regional data and we're
pushing for more data why because
then we can see where we need to focus
more we need to put more resource
into areas so that we can actually get
the numbers up
the government says it's already
delivered three million doses and it
wants to use places like this
to bring 96 of the population within 10
miles
of a vaccination center but they won't
help unless
they've got the doses and in london
despite soaring rates
of infection you're less likely to have
had a job than anywhere else in the
country
london mayor sadiq khan said he was
hugely concerned and that more doses are
urgently required
there are challenges in rural
communities too spalding in lincolnshire
is 15 miles from the nearest vaccination
center and won't get one of its own
until next week i've not heard anything
yet
and i'm in one of the top tiers but just
got to wait and see what happens
the way this is getting worse than ever
i thought they might have pushed it a
little bit more quicker
it's going to take time to get things
organized and it's been rolled out so
yeah somebody's got to be lost in the
queue the only way to release the entire
country from kovid's grip
is to get the vaccine to every part paul
kelso sky news